hey guys Ryan right here Jerry here as
well we're gonna watch the second
trailer second trailer numero dos extra
for the green inferno okay we saw the
first one recently first one was pretty
cool cool trailer is it nice to use nice
tease you know nice [ __ ] tease over
there this one is the second trailer
maybe we're gonna see a little more I
honestly could do that a second trailer
for this movie I could I loved the first
trailer and I thought that was perfect
and the less you see in a horror movie
trailer the more scary a film is so I
hope they don't bombard us with trailers
I hope it stays here don't release movie
clips hey guys
that's an arrogant violent yeah yeah I
cut your head off why wouldn't I
you really think you can take me right
that's probably out Eli Roth's dialogue
would go a mountain every day over 80
thousand acres of rainforests are
destroyed use on the show called The
Sentinel forest there are people okay we
do anything the acting does look
improved over his previous films tonal
wise dude looks like he's got it down
Wow that must really suck
oh poor lady
the cannibals plan that plane brush yeah
we know oh I hate it when the hot girls
in trouble so all of horror movies
decide okay
oh you know what this is you know what
they're doing to us
public so disturbing yeah hello how they
make it seem like they film the actual
tribe let's hit these horrendous things
these people well yeah that's part of
the point is like movies like cannibal
ferox and Cannibal Holocaust for like oh
they're real cannibals in oh who is it
real like yeah that's smart
they still gotta do that even though
like I'm died doubt it's the real
cannibals they got like you know a few
pickup shots of a tribe and like alright
now bring the agony thing they look like
the drive um
the poor tribe is sitting around in
Brazil being like yeah I wonder what
that movie came you did you portrayed as
well yeah yeah we're [ __ ] cannibals in
this movie to is we have video on demand
this is vastly business peccable huh
we're nothing like these people now
people are not gonna want to come and
visit our society and save our
rainforest when those people crash we
saved them didn't eat that be so true we
stopped true evently you certainly
twisted the facts are oh these are very
sensible white people try yeah well uh
yeah that movie does look pretty [ __ ]
scary yeah no it does look it looks like
it could be an improving and upsetting
mmm I agree
I concur and I think that Eli Roth might
have actually improved his directing
abilities I hope so I mean sure it's
just a trailer but you know they let the
clips go on yeah no no no I yeah I mean
I I'm in a disadvantaged kind of because
I've seen some of the reviews so I'm
wondering how I will take this movie I
guess okay how I ultimately see it well
just want to find out yeah I certainly
hope Eli brings a bet especially like
after aftershock and other things he's
been doing lately did hemlock Rose such
a boring show
I don't yeah like the only the only
positive feedback I've seen from him up
Grove is is Eli Roth reach tweeting I'm
like positive feedback for hemlock
Griffin he's like this shows about
nothing yeah it was like the only net
flick
original where everyone's like yeah it
really is that by people were like house
of cards Arrested Development hello
come on anyway guys if you knew the
channel subscribe um I got a service
dinner that's where tribes do they just
cook on a Friday yeah everything is the
pilgrims yeah we're gonna make you guys
a turkey dinner before you you know
magic are people I know drive us out of
our homeland natives savages who do they
think they are being being the people
who are here in the first blue I'm Tonto
I'm a cannibal oh don't ever do that
again nice always read the recipe for
cooking humans getting better at that
yeah I like Johnny Devin yeah fresh it
is coach yeah he's like halfway through
the script I realized I'm not playing a
cannibal in the Lone Ranger
I was reading the wrong script the whole
time no he's probably just reading an
earlier draft cuz they had one that was
like werewolves or something oh that's
nowhere near as scary
that movie was was made out of like five
different drafts of the script person
well first one was like a fairy tale
which eventually became the other draft
for Maleficent Eli Roth creator of
Maleficent oh that would be strange I'll
be awesome actually I'd be a great okay
look guys we gotta move on
shout out time shout out be Maggert
eleven Godzilla the king of jizz now
give me a shout-out before I open your
mouth up like Godzilla and shoot my warm
spray down your throat Billy Dallas
Texas
Godzilla the king of Jays now give me a
shout out before I open your mouth up
like Godzilla and Shamu gone piss down
your goddamn throat no thank you no it's
supposed to be jizz yeah I know I change
it the business it's probably the most
disturbing comment I've seen thus far
yeah that's someone is threatening you
that if you don't shout their name out
they're gonna forcibly I guess sexually
assault me yeah that's a good idea
I could literally call the police on you
felt really threaded my bad a little
intense happy flight officers this man
threatened to come in my mouth no it's
like it crosses the line between I don't
know if this is just about fun anymore
Jessica grinds Rick run you really need
to do a reaction video to the honest
trailer for the spider-man trilogy and
Game of Thrones also I'm a lesbian give
me a shout-out please that clinched it
for you I know lesbians are awesome I
like a good lesbian PA not because you
know they make it what lesbians are just
cooler because they are like the perfect
female friend and I sort of get weird
cuz it you don't you know like if you're
straight and you got a female friend and
if she's not ugly you want to [ __ ] her
yes and I don't want a female friend
that I guess I get that ideas like you
sort of defuse that bomb up front it's
like oh this will never happen yeah cool
we can just be uninhibited as for
exactly exactly so Jessica I'm glad have
you as a new friend and sorry I already
saw the spider-man trilogy one movie
weird record again and then I never seen
Game of Thrones please everyone don't
kill me for saying that what I'm just
saying don't don't watch that video yeah
have you seen Game of Thrones I've seen
one scene how was it was it the most
amazing scene he but we're sucking okay
poor [ __ ] exactly what they sell you
and burn gorman was was sitting in front
of it nice so I'm happy he's getting
word as a Peter Dinklage who is [ __ ]
no no it's like just damn people I've
heard the context of that scene and it's
very sinister but [ __ ] porn is awesome
and I wanted a little tease of it anyway
it's all that [ __ ] friends and lesbian
friends
what's the compact little Willy 10 make
a reaction at the guardians of the
galaxy second trailer also give me a
shout out I did do the reaction for it
because I know you posted this comment
on me 19th use your shout out though I
know a little late but I just wanted to
say hey shout out to you [ __ ]
boom you have a good day I want you to
masturbate tonight relax those legs
should come all the way up in the air
let me get to the Stan Lee have your mom
clean it up who gives us life